[Música]
olá boa tarde a todos eu sou jornalista
e portanto isso nada melhor do que um
jornalista por contar uma história
vamos também contar uma história que é
uma viagem no tempo é uma viagem no
tempo
em 1990 e 1991 eventos uma coisa que nós
todos os anos e que é o outro arguido
foi até um pouco tempo não foi
é impressionante como das nossas vidas
em 1993 foi feito o primeiro registro de
domínios é que o que chama hoje o ponto
pt.org ponto neps conteúdo e em 1993 o
new york times foi o primeiro jornal
o primeiro órgão de comunicação social
que usou um browser
imaginem um browser procurar tudo o que
hoje em dia nós pensamos é obvio que
nessa altura os números muito diferentes
e odiar notícias tinha 150 jornalistas
hoje tem menos 60 tinha vendia em banca
4.049 mil exemplares
dois anos depois foi o pico das vendas e
depois a partir daí começou a cair até o
ano passado e em breve vai haver
novidades sobre isso não vou falar sobre
isso agora é vida é toda a relação do dn
um computador ligado à internet onde eu
estava muitas vezes foi meio dos
computadores mudaram eu acho que também
da época de melhor é e um dia no dia 29
de dezembro de 1995
o diário notícias entrou na internet
pela primeira vez esta é a capa a capa
do jornal que por achar moderno
eu fiz um design de um computador que na
altura se achava moderno e que tinha
aquela senhora que não haverá limite de
vocês provavelmente não sabem sequer o
que é mas quero floppy disk o disquetes
a portuguesa e neste ir
era o aspecto não se conseguem ver da
primeira página do dn na internet em
1995 não faz assim tanto tempo não faz
assim tanto tempo nessa altura foi um
bocadinho aquilo que os jornais fizeram
críticas que abrir uma caixa de pandora
que nunca mais show e que tem trazido
muitos dissabores aos jornais
o dna é grátis a mãe e continua a ser
gratuito online e jornalismo pagas andar
à procura dos factos que deviam
preocupar nos a todos pagas eo
jornalismo de referência pagas ainda
mais porque é difícil é tentar ao poder
é difícil denunciar questões de poder
quando é não está nem aí pra fazer e
quando os que têm de anunciantes
portanto se alguém quer fazer alguma
coisa pelo jornalismo pela democracia
pela sociedade
assim um jornal a mãe por favor porque o
jornalismo e democracia precisa disso
mas eu vou falar de histórias mas é de
mais divertidas nomeadamente desta
crônica que escrevi na que é o jornal em
que eu falava daquele ano como o ano em
que mudar tudo eo marido segundo rezende
que era o diretor do jornal na altura
diz os quentes
ao contrário do que defendem os papéis
da inteligência artificial
as relações sociais não podem ser
compostas ser construídas a partir dali
gritos
temos mais notícias pra eu não é
entretanto não só as relações sociais
foram compostas como foram também
proporcionadas como foram também viradas
como foram também todas organizadas
pelos algoritmos já vamos neste ano 1995
únicos negroponte que alguns de vocês já
conhecem porque estamos numa
universidade de nankin agora muito grata
à tecnologia eu era eu fui o criador
deste livro bendito e também do emitido
massachusetts institute of technology
nomeadamente do seu media lab
neste livro eu dizia e se um dia o
jornal que não distribuirá a porta num
papel eletrônico como aqueles do que
elvira fortunato falava agora esses anos
todos depois costa quase 40
é esse papel fosse de facto definido
porque o que eu quero escolher
aquilo que eu quero ler e eu gosto ler
alguns anos mais tarde mil em 2014
alguém diz que estava a tentar fazer
este jornal que estava a tentar fazer
essa página onde é que o que eu quero
ler o que eu tenho a minha porta
quem era seu agressor era capaz
este rapaz que a mãe na área que todos
conhecem que é o provavelmente a pessoa
com mais influência nas nossas vidas
hoje em dia o mark zuckerberg criou isto
que é um algoritmo de escolha e selecção
de informação que nos chega através da
nossa página do facebook e essa
informação é definir através da
afinidade que nós temos com a informação
do tempo que passamos com informação
semelhante ela e daquilo que chama o
time decaiu seja do tempo que levo é ter
de abandonar essa informação tudo isto e
me implica a relevância da informação
tem pra mim
a relevância que é é que os jornalistas
mais que estavam em mais querem ter um
jornalista quer ser importante na
sociedade é por isso que as pessoas
querem ser jornalistas querem mudar o
mundo
alguns ainda querem mudar o mundo e
aquilo que hoje em dia os algoritmos nos
dão é toda hora é isto
isto é uma página que chama chato beach
e ao minuto o jornalista está a ver quem
estava vendo aquela informação quem está
a ver que está a ler o que eu escrevi
qual foi o resultado disto o resultado
disso é que 60% das pessoas que recebem
as notícias através do facebook estão
condicionadas por esses algoritmos que
nos levam apenas é que o que nós
queremos ver e e criaram aquilo que
muitos autores chamam é que chama as
câmeras deco ou seja o que significa
significa que hoje em dia todos nós
somos apenas confrontados com aquilo que
queremos ver ninguém e confrontar o que
talvez não seja uma boa palavra todos
nós só recebemos aqui eo que queremos
ver
só recebemos aqui o que gostamos de ver
só recebemos aqui o que é confortável
para nós e no tempo que existe
disponível para as pessoas lerem e é
muito pouco tendo em conta que nós hoje
em dia e passámos muito mais de 50
minutos de soldados dois anos são
precisamos muito mais 50 minutos na
internet e significa que nós passamos
muito tempo a ver coisas que apenas
gostamos de ver nunca somos confrontados
com nada
nunca somos confrontados com diferentes
nunca somos nunca nem quando se abre uma
discussão na internet quer sempre vencer
essa discussão que quer sempre ter razão
e que acontece acontece com os meios de
comunicação social também estão a
estreitar nas vistas à casa em portugal
de que isso acontece toda hora
deixou de haver debates deixou de haver
confronto a chover eu tenha sido entre o
exército embora lá discutir o que
acontece nós discutirmos provavelmente
não chegarão outra é mais interessante
90% das pessoas que vivem nos estados
unidos e que votam neste momento
votam em presente eleitorais que em que
as pessoas votam meio gritaria mente no
mesmo partido portanto os nossos
vizinhos são iguais os nossos amigos são
iguais a nós as nossas opiniões que
connosco são compartilhadas aquilo que
não chega através do feed do facebook
são coisas que nós queremos ler que nós
gostamos de ler e nunca vamos nunca
somos confrontados com o diferente
nunca somos confrontados com aquilo que
nos faz impressão
lhes provoca desconforto no fundo
queremos fazer evoluir o nosso
pensamento e então únicos que só fique
um jornalista do new york times escreveu
isto que é neste mundo de de pessoas
salto alto autogeridas em que o mundo se
autogerir nana que o que é transformar a
trans transmissão da informação
as notícias funciona funciona como
narcóticos em pelo menos é uma
autoconfiança tal que faz com que por
exemplo o trampo acho que o aquecimento
global não existe por exemplo qualquer
notícia falsa que diga que ele que o
inter é o que o papa apoiava o
transparece a brasília perto das pessoas
porque no fundo o que elas estão a fazer
é apoiar em sua crença naquilo que está
à volta delas tornando essa crença ainda
maior
tinha um desafio pra preto de rocha era
que fazer um exercício procurar na
internet as aplicações que existem de
vários que nos permitam ser confrontados
no vosso filho facebook com outras
opiniões que não são as vossas existem
várias estão estão difundidos compreende
dois jornais
assim em dois jornais de dentro aumentou
portman opiniões diametralmente opostas
15 minutos por dia que seja fala em com
pessoas que não confiam que não dizem o
mesmo que procurem a opinião de quem não
vos vai dizer sim sim tens toda a razão
procuro em confrontar se procura em ir
buscar na memória de quem não viveu o
que vocês viveram e que podem nos dar
uma visão diferente do mundo porque a
democracia precisa disto porque não
crescia 2 em barracas como diz hoje em
tripoli a democracia morta no silêncio
na escuridão e nós temos todos a
contribuir quando não somos quando não
confundo quando confrontados no facebook
por exemplo como opinião que é diferente
nós quando ele quando reagimos com tal
violência
nós vamos chamar mais um querem cavar
mais um bocadinho é é a cova da
democracia para dar mais um prego no
caixão daquilo que é a opinião de frente
uns pensar em uma coisa outros outras
fazerem o ine ano tivemos aqui uma um
concerto falava disto eu sou assim é
como pode andar pra frente também 15
minutos podia pensar em frente por favor
[Aplausos]